وسط تدهور للعلاقه بين البلدين اثري
احتجاز ايران سبعه مواطنين فرنسيين اكد
الرئيس الفرنسي على دعم النساء الايرانيات
التي بنسبه اليه هي خذنا كفاحهن بشجاعه
استثنائيه على حساب حياتهم وحياتي احبائهم
التي يدافعنا عنها ليست مجرد كلمات وقد
فقدنا امهاتهن واخواتهن وابائهم ويتحدثنا
معك عن حقوق الانسان ليس كمفهوم ولكن
ببساطه
اعلى ايضا عن عقوبات اوروبيه جديده على
ايران تستهدف هذه المره الدائره الداخليه
للحاله الثوري الايراني
فيما اعلن مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعي
للامم المتحده عن عقد جلسه خاصه في الربع
والعشرين من نوفمبر الجاري لبحث تدهور
لوضع حقوق الانسان في ايران المجلس كان قد
اذن استخدام طهران للقوه على نطاق واسعه
ضد المحتاجين السلميين الذين يستمرون في
احتجاجاتهم اليوميه منذ وفاه مهس امين في
السادس عشر من سبتمبر الماضي بعد احتجاز
شرطه الاخلاق لها